we have a general sense that these sort
of places are filled with things that
are deeply important but what exactly is
literature good for why should we spend
our time reading novels or poems when
out there big things are going on
let's have a think about some of the
ways that literature benefits us
of course it looks like it's wasting
time but literature is ultimately the
greatest time saver because it gives us
access to a range of emotions and events
that it would take you years decades
millennia to try to experience directly
literature is the greatest reality
simulator a machine that puts you
through infinitely more situations than
you could ever directly witness
it lets you safely that's crucial see
what it's like to get divorced or kill
someone and feel remorseful or chuck in
your job and take off to the desert or
make a terrible mistake while leading
your country
it lets you speed up time in order to
see the arc of a life from childhood to
old age it gives you the keys to the
palace into countless bedrooms so you
can assess your life in relation to that
of others
it introduces you to fascinating people
a roman general an 11th century french
princess a russian upperclass mother
just embarking on an affair
it takes you across continents and
centuries literature cures you of
provincialism and at almost no cost
turns us into citizens of the world
literature performs the basic magic of
showing us what things look like from
someone else's point of view it allows
us to consider the consequences of our
actions on others in a way we otherwise
wouldn't and it shows us examples of
kindly generous sympathetic people
literature typically stands opposed to
the dominant value system the one that
rewards money and power
writers are on the other side they make
us sympathetic to ideas and feelings
that are of deep importance but that
can't afford air time in a
commercialized status conscious and
cynical world
we're weirder than we're allowed to
admit we often can't say what's really
on our minds but in books we find
descriptions of who we genuinely are and
what events are actually like described
with an honesty quite different from
what ordinary conversation allows for
in the best books it's as if the writer
knows us better than we know ourselves
they find the words to describe the
fragile weird special experiences of our
inner lives the light on a summer
morning the anxiety we felt at the
gathering the sensations of a first kiss
the envy when a friend told us of their
new business the longing we experienced
in the train looking at the profile of
another passenger we never dared to
speak to
writers open our hearts and minds and
give us maps to our own selves so that
we can travel in them more reliably and
with less of a feeling of paranoia and
persecution
as the writer emerson remarked in the
works of great writers we find our own
neglected thoughts literature is a
corrective to the superficiality and
compromises of friendship books are our
true friends always to hand never too
busy giving us unvarnished accounts of
what things are really like
all of our lives one of our greatest
fears is a failing of messing up of
becoming as the tabloids put it a loser
every day the media takes us into
stories of failure
interestingly a lot of literature is
also about failure in one way or another
a great many novels plays poems are
about people who messed up people who
slept with mum by mistake or who let
down their partner or who died after
running up some debts on shopping sprees
if the media got to them they'd make
mincemeat out of them
but great books don't judge as harshly
or as one-dimensionally as the media
they evoke pity for the hero who fear
for ourselves based on a new sense of
how near we all are to destroy our own
lives
but if literature can really do all
these things we might need to treat it a
bit differently to the way we do now
we tend to treat it as a distraction an
entertainment something for the beach
but it's far more than that it's really
therapy in the broad sense
we should learn to treat it as doctors
treat their medicines something we
prescribe in response to a range of
ailments and classify according to the
problems it might best be suited to
addressing
literature deserves its prestige for one
reason above all others because it's a
tool to help us live and die with a
little bit more wisdom goodness insanity
you